there is eric lower he's been great as a
starter for the crew this year rock
yeah making start number four three of
his start so far this year have been
quality start robbie grossman hitting
from the right side of the plate
it's a swing and a miss there with a
fastball on grossman off to a good start
eric lower
[Applause]
swinging in the miss
climb the ladder with the high fastball
there back-to-back punch out starts the
day for lauer
lowers average fastball about 92-93
miles an hour and you can see
right there muscling up at 95. he's
feeling pretty good tonight two down on
nico goodrum flower one more time here
he comes struck him out swinging
and the inning is over
he winds up striking out the side
the air and a base hit
no further damage done matthew boyd will
make his 11th start of the season he's
coming off
a rather uh clunker in his words i would
say
and quite honestly has not fared well
against national league teams in
national league ballparks with all that
being said he's due to have a gem one
ball one strike he gets that ball and he
goes over four yesterday for wong did
score a run hits this one in the air to
right drifting back reyes he's running
out of room one nothing brewer he's one
batter into the game
a 1-1 pitch
wrong able to pick with a slider
there's a good start for the crew colton
wong on the board with a base with a
home run first home run since april 28th
against miami
that slider down the middle of the plate
didn't do a whole lot and colton wong
gave it a pretty good ride to right
instant offense
awesome
one takes it to left and it's gone
eric haas has tied it up with one swing
of the bat leading off the second that's
his third homer of the year 1-1 well
here's a kid that is really looking for
a hit
he's been scuffling lately at the plate
and yet he's so aggressive and has that
within him right we all know that
this kid could potentially hit a home
run almost every at-bat it's a slider
that stays down in the zone kinda in his
wheelhouse high-fives everywhere for
eric haas well he's got the bases loaded
now and miguel cabrera is the batter big
time trouble with two away here's the
1-1
drives one to right center field and
that's going to get up the alley up
against the wall
miguel cabrera comes through with a huge
hit here and the tigers put up a big
crooked number he clears the bases
with an rbi double
miguel cabrera
his 400th
double as a tiger well they're going to
authenticate this baseball also miguel
making some magic happen here what a hit
what a time for a hit
he gets another fastball after missing
one right down the middle or taking one
this ball's elevated a little bit more
outer half
and he just
greets it with a great swing and jamers
holland cleo to bases
scope drives one to deep left field that
ball is entered and gone
a two-run blast for jonathan scope and
the tigers have opened up a can here in
the second
that was a can of whoop right there
jonathan was sitting on that pitch and
he put a big time swing on it
and i love crooked numbers
jonathan scope adds two more
watch this pitch watch the swing
inner half and he barrels it that's just
opening up early
third home run in the last five games
for jonathan scope
it's 6-1 tigers tyrone taylor is on deck
for the brewers hoping his bat stays hot
as he moves north from nashville back to
milwaukee taylor to right this is well
struck reyes back warning trek looks up
gone
tyrone taylor welcome back his fourth
home run of the season he stays hot
not just down in the minor leagues
boy that's a nice swing going to the
opposite field that was a change up that
was away boyd left it up a little bit
and he went right with
it that's a good piece of hitting by
tyrone taylor when a change up goes
right with it that is a big strong young
man right there first game back tonight
and he goes yard eric lauer is still on
the mound give up six last inning to get
started with an air cost home run he
needed six two this one to straight away
center
taylor still going back that ball is
gone eric haas a two homer knight he had
one earlier this season he does it again
here in milwaukee well good for him this
ball carried
and kept carrying here you see the ball
and there it is it goes and hits the
back concrete after hitting the top of
the wall so that's clearly a home run
three homers on the night for the tigers
two by haas one by scope the offensive
onslaught continues brewers just try to
get a little back each inning only trail
by five runs
this one's driven out to deep right by
colton wong that is his second of the
game
brewers hoping to get back in it it's
now 7-4 he's he's been everything we
could have asked for on the defensive
side of the ball and we're beginning to
see the offensive upside that a lot of
people have thought he's had for a long
time in st louis he hit a slider for a
home run in the first inning as well
colton wong getting the job done at the
top of the brewer's order and boy
doesn't that change the complexion of
this game in a hurry adrian hauser needs
a strike
good pitch by hauser and strikes out
willie castro for out number one here in
the fifth it drops the curveball on him
down out of the strike zone and a very
defensive swing by castro now the
stretch here it is
swinging him out struck him out
fastball at 95 up and away and grossman
went after it and the pitch
got him looking on the outside corner
adrian houser no further damage garcia
the former tiger trying to lock it in
line drive center field it is going to
get by goodrum
watch yelling run he's around third he's
going to score
it's an rbi double for garcia and a
clutch two out run for the brewers oh my
goodness i mean i just love watching
christian yellows run the bases poetry
and motion around the bags effortless
one out that brings up jonathan scope
two for three for scope tonight turns on
one sends it to deep left field that's a
two-homer night for scope it is chuck
and duck night in downtown milwaukee
jonathan scope similar to his other home
run gets one on inner half and turns on
it and there is your tigers home run
leader and the battering is going to be
tyrone taylor
swinging a high fly to deep left tyrone
taylor has gone deep again
another multi-homer game
between the tigers and brewers
fastball down and then just drops the
head of the bat on it brewers down by
two two and one now to willy castro a
couple extra insurance runs would be
beneficiary
[Applause]
fly ball left field
yelich under it
haas tags
the throw comes into third and the
tigers now lead at 9-6 nomar mazar at
the plate man it's second one out
zara sends one to deep left field
that is a fair ball and you're going to
get another run home double digit runs
for the tigers nomar mazzara joins that
rbi parade he's got an rbi double 10-6
detroit maria soto
fly ball deep left field back grossman
warning track another one for the
brewers
five homers tonight for the cold
sixth home run of the season for the
brewers third baseman tonight right into
the brewers bullpen ten seven two outs
in the ninth inning ten seven tigers
another two two
he stuck him out
a 99 mile an hour fastball painted
down low that's the way to end it and
the tigers split the series in milwaukee